so i have to say susan it is almost
impossible for a book to genuinely
set off a revolution of some kind but i
think that your book actually did it
and i laughed but you struck such a cord
and then there were so many people that
were kind of suffering in silence
but before your book came along
and then it it feels like you kind of
unlocked or unleashed all of this
uh suffering and potential energy around
trying to build
workplaces and a society that are more
mindful
of folks who become overstimulated by
various
uh social situations um
it's it's really been incredible uh how
did you
end up plugging into this work initially
and then tell us about
really the last number of years because
this book came out
in 2012 and since then you've had two
ted talks uh two sequels to the book
uh a genuine organization that is
actually making a huge difference in
people's lives
um so this is a very long-winded way of
asking first did you ever imagine that
it was going to reach this level when
you first started writing this book
oh my gosh not at all um
so you know my path was like you i was a
corporate lawyer at a
very similar firm i was at cleary
gottlieb and um
but i i had always wanted to be a writer
since i was a kid
and um and when i stopped practicing
i wrote all kinds of things for a few
years never
tried to publish anything but i was
writing plays and essays and
poetry and memoir all kinds of stuff
and and then i started working on this
project about
introverts and i thought of it
as this quirky project that i was doing
on the side
for some reason this was the project
that i decided i was going to actually
try to get published
you know as opposed to all the other
stuff i'd been writing
but even though i was i started working
on a book proposal and you know went
into the whole publishing thing
um yeah i thought of it as my
quirky idiosyncratic take on the world
i thought i'd be happy if the book got
published and
you know and a few people bought it but
i had no idea of the nerve it was going
to tap when i first started working on
it
you know for the for the reason that i
think you just touched on which is
most people have been experiencing
what it's like to be an introvert in an
extroverted culture
in silence no one ever talks about it no
one ever did talk about it
so i didn't know that so many people
felt that way
and i also didn't know so many people
who felt that way would
be so happy to come forward and start
chatting about it
as they did but i got my first inkling
when my agent and i uh first pitched the
book proposal
uh to the publishing houses and you know
it set off this crazy auction
and i started meeting with all the
different houses and
one by having all these meetings and one
by one everybody started identifying
themselves as introverts um so i'm sure
the publishing world
is very introvert heavy it is it is but
so this is the thing that kept happening
so you could so so that's what i said to
myself you know that was when i
it was all just beginning and i thought
okay well that's just the publishing
world
that's a really introverted space right
because it's
book people but then
some years later after i had written it
the book came out and the first thing i
did practically was give a ted talk
about it
um and you know you know ted is this
environment of all these
sort of mover shaker type people um
lots of ceos and people uh
kind of striding across the world in one
way or another um but
in that environment too i i happened to
be one of the first speakers and
i came off the stage and was immediately
surrounded by
all these other people all these people
who were telling me that they too were
secret introverts and they had never
talked about it before or they had never
even
realized it themselves but that's really
who they were
and uh and this is what started to
happen no matter what environment
uh i found myself in you know like half
the people
were talking about how intensely
uh this described their story something
like a quarter to a half of all people
are introverts is that correct yeah
that's right there's different studies
and
so one study found that it was about a
third of americans
and another study 50 so you know i think
we're safe to estimate that it's one out
of every
two or three people that you know you
know so
that's a lot of people in your family in
your workplace
in your campaign anywhere you go so
you pitch your book
uh there's a frenzy around it you're
like huh that's different yeah that's a
good way of putting it
was a kind of bemusement you do a ted
talk and you realize that a lot of the
techies
were introverted nerds too which does
not shock me
right
right chris anderson knew from the
beginning um he had a sense that the
audience would
would uh resonate so then the book takes
off
and then what is that time like yeah so
then after that it just became
um a kind of non-stop
whirlwind from one world to another
um i mean okay so first of all it was
like hundreds or thousands
of letters and conversations and
so on with just one human after another
um talking about how
this concept was giving them a sense of
permission
finally to be who they are who they
actually
are and that word permission is the word
that people use over and over again
um like i don't think we realize
that the degree to which it just becomes
habit for
introverts to not feel permission to do
what they want to do
you know it's as some as simple as like
okay how are you going to spend your
free saturday afternoon
you know you might really want to just
be hanging out
by yourself and there's just this
feeling that gets bred into us from a
very early age that there's something
wrong with that choice um so
so the first answer to your question is
that it was just this incredibly moving
and humbling series of
conversations with one one person after
another you know talking about their
life experiences and then the other
aspect of it has been
watching the ways in which
these ideas can really improve
institutions you know whether you're
talking about schools
or sports teams or or companies
and i've been so gratified to see
how open and willing people are to
embrace these these kinds of ideas you
know because the message is kind of like
well you know as an institution this
this if i'm speaking to a school or if
i'm speaking to a company the message is
well as an institution you haven't been
getting it right thus far
and and you can imagine that being a
message that people would resist
but that hasn't happened i've found
instead that people are really receptive
and you know they get it we're talking
about half of our population why would
we not want to
get it right why why would we not want
to make a few tweaks that would
harness the energies and the talents of
half our populations
why would we not do that i've seen this
adopted now
in every kind of institution that you
can imagine
and it's just incredibly exciting let's
say that someone listening to this right
now
is a manager and he's thinking oh
you mean like maybe there's something i
can do that will actually help some of
my
people feel more comfortable or be in
better position to produce
like what kind of tweaks are we talking
about in a typical organization how do
they
do things customarily and then how
might they tweak it well there's really
a lot
you know the number one thing would be
getting this to
just be a subject that people talk about
readily and comfortably
and where you can kind of just joke
around with each other about
what everyone's temperament is like i'm
just thinking of a conversation that i
had with
a professor bob sutton um business
school professor and and he was talking
about how
so many um so many academics are
introverts and that
there's a way in which many academic
institutions
make it comfortable for their professors
to be that way and i asked him
well what do they do to make it
comfortable and he said you know it
it's it's a kind of intangible thing
it's just a kind of joking around of
like yeah of course
um you're gonna want you just taught a
class of course you're going to want to
go off and take a break now
um it's just it's an affectionate
comfortable
easy joking around about these
differences
so so the first thing i'm talking about
is a just a sort of shift of
consciousness
but in terms of specifics there's a lot
um one thing would be to be become more
mindful of how many
meetings you are having and how many of
them
are actually necessary um and then when
you
do need to meet um as a staff
as a team how how are those meetings
conducted and how much
exhausting self-presentation is
involved as opposed to just the
pure exchange of ideas or the pure
enjoyment of each other's company
um so you know now of course we're in
the age of zoom
well do all those meetings that you're
doing actually need to be
conducted via video because for a lot of
people
and this is true for extroverts too um
the video component of zoom
adds a whole other layer of exhaustion
um for lots of reasons that we could
talk about
and is it really necessary
[Music]
you